at the very northernmost point of
Mainland Britain just down the coast
from jono Groats and the lighthouse had
done it head
you'll find a very intriguing Place
indeed
from the outside this might look like
just another industrial building but
inside
you'll find a small group of people
making some very special batteries
this place is one of the hidden secrets
of British manufacturing they've been
making lithium-ion cells here for more
than 30 years this Machinery was feeding
stuff going into military applications
now they've got exciting plans for the
future the problem is it's not entirely
clear that this country is the right
place to be putting them into action
why America is throwing money at
companies like this making green
technologies to come and make them in
the US
it's part of something called the
inflation reduction act a multi-billion
dollar set of subsidies for anyone
making these kinds of Technologies in
America raising the question why stay
here
we are a home-grown UK business we see
ourselves as a UK company we've
developed the technology here we want to
commercialize the technology here and we
want to manufacture the product here
that is our absolute desire we have to
ask the question if the subsidies are
available overseas and it's immensely
compelling arguments it's something that
we do have to consider but we want to
stay in the UK there's no question about
that
it's not just making waves on the
northern coast of Scotland
across the Atlantic in Richmond Virginia
you can feel the impact
when we're on a nice white roof like
this the sunlight can pass through the
modules secure solar has been installing
a raise like this for years but in the
past year Everything's changed
a huge uptick in interest from customers
looking to install solar you know we're
we're at the point you know struggling
to get solar modules because there is so
much interest in projects we've seen
we've had roughly a 50 jump in business
in the first quarter of this year
sometimes said we're living through a
new Industrial Revolution at the moment
and what's really striking is just how
aggressive America is being about it
they're saying they want this revolution
to happen here they didn't just want to
be buying in this stuff from abroad they
want to be making it themselves
these panels were made in America but
the firm which made them went bust it
can compete with China the ACT wants to
draw production back to the US but it's
also drawing business away from
everywhere else like the UK and Europe
the EU is bolstering its own green funds
there's a master fund are already
underway within the European Union you
know we listen very carefully to what
European industry has to say
um but we do need a response that will
work over the medium to long term
all of which raises the question what
about the UK how is Britain responding
to the biggest shift in American
industrial policy in half a century
the chancellor invited us along to some
of his meetings in Washington DC this
week here he is with the head of the IMF
talking about their economic forecasts
we're very focused on proven you wrong
excellent but uh thank you nice to see
you with companies threatening a green
Exodus is he going to produce our own
inflation reduction act if you depend
entirely on subsidies there's a risk
when you take the subsidies away you can
end up with a business that's not viable
and so our model in the UK is a
combination of of some support to get
businesses off the ground but then some
Market regulatory changes that mean
those businesses have a long-term future
and investment incentives through the
tax system are you concerned at all
about inflation reduction acts being
somewhat protectionist we can be
sensible and pragmatic and develop
Supply chains Source through our friends
sometimes through ourselves and continue
to benefit from sharing and benefiting
mutually from technology if we were to
turn our backs on free trade that would
be a disaster for the world economy we
would be turning the clock right back
and we would enter into a dark ages
period so we do not want to move to
protectionism
the problem is the clock is ticking and
with America having made an offer many
companies can't afford to refuse the
suspicion is there'll be yet more
businesses departing these Shores in the
coming years Ed Conway Sky News
foreign